some of animations most memorable
characters seem like real people partly
because their appearance and
personalities were actually inspired by
real people here are a few memorable
examples of beloved cartoon characters
and their real-life counterparts
mr. burns of The Simpsons it took a
little bit of a lots of fearsome
individuals to add up to the most evil
man in Springfield Simpsons creator Matt
Groening safety got burns demeanor and
some of his appearance from David Bailey
his high school math teacher I'm a
capitalist do I believe in the free
enterprise system
yes check am i greedy you know I think a
very generous person then he added in a
little bit of standard oil tycoon john d
rockefeller
so hid appear more like quote the
embodiment of corporate greed family
religion friendship these are the three
demons you must slay if you wish to
Succeed in Business when it came time to
render him in cartoon form animator
David Silverman took other inspirations
including the body parts of a praying
mantis and the head and face of Barry
Diller the founder of the Fox Network
Bugs Bunny
the reason Bugs Bunny eats carrots have
more to do with classic Hollywood movie
star Clark Gable than the dietary
preferences of real rabbits probably
best known today for his role as Rhett
Butler in 1939 Gone with the Wind
gable won the Academy Award for Best
Actor for the 1934 comedy It Happened
One Night portraying a sarcastic and
scrappy unemployed newspaper reporter in
one scene he discusses of hitchhiking
skills while munching on a carrot Marin
Orianna arrow you're next bit expert I'm
going to write a book about animate surf
Friz Freleng said he lifted Gables
behavior in the scene when creating the
sarcastic and scrappy bugs I love you I
hope it is
Rocko Rocko's Modern Life
Rocko is anxious overwhelmed and out of
step with the world around him like the
stock male character in a number of
Woody Allen movies often played by Allen
himself in his page to Nickelodeon
Rocko's Modern Life creator Joe Murray
describes a social character a wallaby
with an Australian accent at the young
anthropomorphic Woody Allen who had just
moved away from home into a surrealistic
adult world Troy McClure The Simpsons
you might remember him from The Simpsons
of an actor and heartthrob well past his
prime who can only get work in B movies
educational films and infomercials a few
weeks ago I was a washed-up actor with a
drinking problem then Brad Goodman came
along and gave me this job and a can of
fortified wine his name combines two
hunky actors who have been largely
forgotten Troy Donahue and Doug McClure
Simpsons writer Mike Reiss revealed on a
Simpsons DVD commentary track that he
met Doug McClure daughter who told him
her dad figured out they were making fun
of him and that his kids called him Troy
when he wasn't in the room that's brutal
Chucky Rugrats well he still might be
best known as a frontman of
forward-thinking rock bands Evo Mark
Mothersbaugh was now one of the most
sought-after film composers working in
movies on TV not only did he create
Rugrats memorably weird sense and vocal
based music
but his unique personal style also
inspired the design of Chucky one of the
show's lead characters Ursula the Little
Mermaid the villainous sea witch in the
1989 Disney classic was inspired by
Glenn Milstead better known as divine
star of several John Waters films Little
Mermaid lyricist and producer Howard
Ashman knew divine having once
frequented the same underground club
scene in Baltimore Ashman worked with
Disney artists on preliminary sketches
to add in a shock of hair a ton of
eyeshadow and other features that made
us than look almost exactly like divine
Krusty the Klown The Simpsons in the
early days of television a guy named
James Allen better known as rusty nails
had a show on local Portland TV that's
aired on Saturday mornings Simpsons
creator Matt Groening a grew up in
Portland and watched the show as a kid
and created Krusty the Klown in honor of
rusty although he says rusty wasn't
nearly as early and disenchanted I could
pull a little cartoon out of my hair hey
whoa
wasn't that great kid but as South Park
Eric Staal has been helping make South
Park since the early 1990s when it was
just a couple of crude the animated
Christmas themed shorts today style
still words of the animation director
for the long-running series another
indelible contribution to the show he's
the inspiration for the sweet naive
innocence and incredibly unlucky butters
style say it is almost as agreeable as
butters and had a similar strict
upbringing the other South Park guys
once nicknamed him little brother which
evolved into little buddy
then butters then butters Kim Kardashian
is so cheeky her butt is like a big
mound of pudding thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're left
[Music]